[Music]
hey what's up guys i'm kphd here
and oneplus nord is here it's official
as you probably already know by the
avalanche in your sub box or maybe not
maybe this is the first time
you're ever hearing about this phone so
i dropped my first impressions video and
all the specs and all the official stuff
about a week ago you can check out that
video if you haven't seen it already
this is the full review
i'm going to button some things up and
also just talk about
this place oneplus is in and the truth
behind this phone so like i said in that
impressions video and i'll stand by this
pretty much every part of this phone
is second best for the price meaning
there's not going to be a super standout
flagship spec
in any place in this phone but all of
them are going to be
right up there with the best so the
display is maybe the best example of
this
it's a 1080p 90 hertz oled display
so not the bleeding edge highest
resolution or
highest frame rate but still quite nice
and i've said i really like that it's a
flat display
and that the bezels aren't too thick now
to pixel peep a little bit i do
see some off-axis rainbowing and some
tint issues
but it's minor and overall this screen
is better than fine and then same with
the specs snapdragon 765 and i'm using
the model with 12 gigs of ram
and 256 gigs of storage now it's no 800
series
and it is ufs 2.1 storage and honestly
just feels a bit slower
especially with the heavier stuff like
launching the big apps
like the games and the camera that's
where it's a little more noticeable
but overall it's fine you know oxygen os
for me has felt more or less like the
same
experience as the more expensive oneplus
8 plus
you have the bonus of 5g compatibility
now now again in that first impressions
video i talked about the quality of the
build
feels good in the hand metal and glass
that's not entirely true or accurate
about this phone so
it is glass on the front and the back
and it's plastic rails along the
outsides
and metal buttons so it's metal glass
and plastic not that there's anything
wrong with plastic we see it all the
time especially in lower priced phones
and it's
technically more durable than glass a
lot of times here it is painted to look
like metal
but like i said second best okay so the
other main things that we were waiting
for the full review to talk about were
the battery life and the cameras so
like which do you want first the good
news of the bad news i think most people
would probably pick
the good news which is the battery and
turns out the battery is
quite good it's a little over 4 100
milliamp hours as you may remember
and it was getting me comfortably
through the end of all types of
quarantine days
five hours of screen on time no problem
ending the lighter days
with sometimes 20 or 30 left and it was
definitely helped massively by
it coming with the warp charger in the
box i can't
understate how important that was for
this phone now it actually comes with
the
the european plug in the box since this
phone's not coming to the us
but i happen to already have a us warp
charge 30t
plug already plus there's one in my car
i've been a fan of fast charging for a
long time so this phone
in the battery department definitely
doesn't disappoint really it's in this
price range only second place to like
the crazy the more gimmicky energizer
phone
types you remember that did you guys
know energizer made a phone
the battery company that was a trip so
then
the cameras the bad news and really like
it's it's more of
it's just kind of a mixed bag at this
point i really think they've fallen
victim to their own marketing
department's hype so it's a quad camera
system on the back
all right 48 megapixel main camera with
the hardware straight from the oneplus 8
then an 8 megapixel ultra ride camera a
two megapixel macro camera
and five megapixel depth sensor
okay let me try to be diplomatic here
the main camera
is okay it's the same hardware as the
oneplus 8 but it doesn't quite
take the same photos i found it's
actually a little bit
noisier a little worse overall but
definitely in the same league decent
photos
if you don't pixel peep too much but
once you zoom in you probably won't be
too impressed by detail
or anything like that it's fine the
ultrawide camera
it does its job with the whole dramatic
wide perspective for sure
but it's immediately soft so no matter
what the lighting conditions
it's just lacking the resolution
fundamentally to match the quality of
the primary camera in a wider field of
view you'd actually need a higher
resolution
than the main camera to achieve this but
you know maybe that's just for flagships
nevertheless i'm fine that it's here so
you can probably see where this is going
the 2 megapixel macro camera on the back
of this phone
is just unnecessary because it is so bad
and i think even oneplus would know
right away it's basically
to increase the count of the cameras on
the phone and it's not actually
here to be a great quality camera and
actually you want to know the biggest
tell the reason you know oneplus knows
this
uh oneplus 8 pro has a macro camera and
there's actually a software feature
where if you get close to a subject it
automatically switches the camera
to macro mode because it's a good camera
it's useful it'll be high quality this
phone the nord
absolutely doesn't do that it never
automatically switches
to that separate macro camera because
often the photos from this macro camera
are actually worse than if you just use
the main camera and get as close as you
can
and then crop in that's not an
exaggeration seriously i try this a few
times and almost every time i just take
the photo from the main camera
crop in a bit and when you put it next
to the macro version
it's usually better and this makes the
additional camera module
feel pointless and then there's the
depth camera which
in theory should make for some improved
portrait shots
and they they look pretty good mostly
with some occasionally
quirky edge detection but then i covered
the depth sensor with my finger
and kept shooting and it didn't complain
once and continued to take
basically the same quality portrait
shots i think it's pretty clear oneplus
and a bunch of other companies it's not
just them but in phones like this
they want to put a triple or a quad
camera set up
so that it looks like visually it looks
like
one of those flagship phones and when
you look at the spec sheet it says quad
cameras
just like a flagship but because it's
not and they're trying to save money
they have to cut the quality
of at least that second and third camera
so
here's a crazy idea i don't know if i've
said this before but
just get rid of those last two cameras
that are so bad that they're useless
and put that money you save into
something else because the camera really
is one of those places where you can
just cut the fat like that
now a place where you can't the speaker
on this phone right
it's a bad single channel it's a mono
downward facing speaker you can block it
easily low quality
tinny not very loud it's just bad but
it's better than not having a speaker at
all so they just put that speaker in
there
and it's functional but these cameras
the logical thing to do here is cut it
down to maybe one
maybe two cameras if you need them and
take the money saved and put them into
other things that might be more
noticeable like wireless charging
or a metal frame or just better primary
cameras but either way that's just my
opinion it's something they could do but
clearly have chosen not to but that
brings us to my conclusion
now in case i wasn't abundantly clear i
really like this phone
and with the promised two years of
software updates and three years of
security updates i'm actually confident
i could easily daily this phone for a
couple years and be happy but the truth
about oneplus nord is
this was inevitable like oneplus right
now
doesn't quite have the brand clout to
compete at
over a thousand bucks now that's
definitely goals they're getting there
they're closing in
but still like ask your five closest
friends what they think of oneplus
phones
and guarantee there's a couple of them
that haven't even heard of oneplus yet
and that is tough to convince people to
buy something at over a thousand bucks
from a brand they've never heard of
over apple and samsung the dominating
players
and oneplus knows that so they know
their goal is and probably always has
been to get to the point where they can
compete and sell those high margin
thousand dollar flagships but if they do
that
they're kind of abandoning what got them
there in the first place
which is all this name recognition for
good high quality
cheaper phones so as their phones year
after year after year moved up
and up and up over and over again in
price it was inevitable that they had to
come up with something
down here to fill in the gap to keep
building that brand cash and keep
building that reputation of making good
quality phones
for the price while this continues to
evolve the only difference now though is
they can't make this a flagship killer
because
they make a flagship now and they're not
trying to cannibalize their own sales
so this has to be a distinctly mid-range
separate experience separate branding
separate
phone so that it doesn't interrupt with
or overlap
with their flagship so honestly we could
have seen this coming when these phones
came out
do you think it's coincidence that for
the first time in the years and years
and years of oneplus phones they finally
added
wireless charging the ip certification
just those
last couple things people were asking
them to add so that they can compete at
the high price
no they added all those things to this
higher end phone to compete of course
and make it a better phone but also now
it makes a perfect opening for a couple
months later
oneplus nord to slide in and have
basically all the same
smart trade-offs that they've been doing
over the years with their flagships from
like
2015 up until now what are the downsides
of this phone
no ip certification no headphone jacks
sub-par
cameras a little bit lower end stuff but
just making the right cutoffs and at the
end of the day
they've made the right trade-offs if
you're shopping for a phone anywhere
under 500 bucks
or 500 euros or 30 000 rupees or
whatever that magical price range is for
you
this is something to look at no question
easy to recommend easy to consider
but now i'm looking forward to the rest
of what the nord
range will bring i think inevitably
there's a version of this that comes to
the us
and i'll be excited waiting for that so
there you go there you have it it's the
truth about oneplus nord
feel free to leave a like if you enjoyed
this video and subscribe if you haven't
already to see more videos like this
thank you for watching catch you guys in
the next one
peace
you